bon les et pas n'importe lequel le flash
un bus à haut niveau de service qui a
beaucoup fait parler de lui surtout à
cause du nouveau plan de circulation mis
en place conscient de la polémique le
député maire sortant assume je crois que
c'est important qu'ils y compris ceux
qui prennent pas le bus réalise qu'on a
besoin malgré tout d'avoir une
infrastructure qui puisse correspondre à
ce que nos habitants nous demander la
preuve la fréquentation en hausse en est
la démonstration ce but relie la gare de
chalon et la zone industrielle nord
rebaptisée sonné or le symbole d'un
développement économique dont le maire
sortant fait sa priorité
le maire et ses colistiers venus de tous
les horizons ou presque des communistes
il y a des socialistes il y à des
radicaux il ya des écologistes il ya des
citoyens il y a des gens qui étaient au
modem il n'ya pas longtemps il y a deux
anciens l'adjoint de dominique perben
donc c'est une liste dont on voit bien
qu'elle est la liste du rassemblement
le rassemblement un mot très à la mode à
chalon jusque sur la place de l'hôtel de
ville où un face-à-face s'affiche en
grand le chef de l'opposition municipale
gilles platret repart en campagne et lui
non plus n'est pas tout seul c'est même
à trio qui reçoit les habitants dans la
permanence mobile du candidat moi j'ai
pris l'engagement d'être amère à plein
temps si je suis évidement ça veut dire
concrètement c'est à mercier à la fois
dans son bureau pour recevoir les
citoyens utile vient aussi au devant
d'eux donc la permanence qu'on lance
pour cette campagne est là quelque part
vocation à continuer après la campagne à
la rencontre des habitants
oubliez les dissensions pour désigner la
tête de liste gilles platret sébastien
martins et isabelle de chaume sont
aujourd'hui délibérément trois contre un
prêt à reconquérir la ville
enlevé par la gauche en 2008 on n'est
pas du tout dans un esprit de revanche
je pense que les chalonnais attendre
beaucoup mieux et beaucoup plus que ça
ils attendent des réponses concrètes à
leurs questions pas forcément des
projets des promesses à des dizaines de
millions d'euros mais des choses
concrètes pour le soucier du quotidien
des soucis du quotidien sur lesquels le
front national compte bien capitaliser
c'est ghislaine launay et pousse de l'ex
numéro 1 départemental du fn qui se
lancent dans la bataille mais florian de
tonic son directeur de campagne qui ce
jour-là s'exprimer au nom de la
candidate leur parti compte bien faire
mieux
les quatre pour cent de 2008 beaucoup
bougé dans chalon peut plus se garer
donc voilà non c'est vrai que c'est
vraiment pas les gens ils analysent en
disant non marcquois les impôts qui
monte
non c'est vrai qu'à chalon ils ont ils
sont mécontents de de christophe sirugue
et du gouvernement en général 4e
candidat en lice à chalon pascal
dufresne y porte comme il ya six ans les
couleurs de lutte ouvrière il lance lui
aussi un appel au vote de contestation
les ouvriers en ont marre de faire les
frais de la crise marre de tous ces
politiciens du parti socialiste du fn et
de l'ump de ces trois partis qui tous au
pouvoir ou quand ils ont des
responsabilités défend le camp des
riches
donc nous n'avons rien à voir avec ces
trois parties la est parti en ordre de
bataille sur les bords de saône où la
situation pour christophe sirugue est
bien différente d'il ya six ans